so I've been in New York for about like
six years now I grew up in New Jersey I
work in Tech I like the outdoors well I
mean Tech myself though nice I think
that he's going to pick someone that
could be like his best friend what
industry you you work in so I work in
Consulting now I'm I guess a doctor
doing consulting for Pharma companies
I'm a designer and I also love having
fun I throw events though parties so I
just like bringing people together yeah
what about yourself at night I'm doing
composing and I'm in the Band oh really
what instruments I play keyboard I
recently just started selling bikes
online and it's picking up that's where
I focus most my attention give me the
bike the bike store yeah I feel like he
could have roasted them more the way he
roasts me he's like super blunt and
honest usually